ouais bah oui c'est parti un gps aux
accents ch'tis d'avis à m tourner à
gauche du sud europe et prend la sixième
sortie est toulousain allez on met les
voiles ce sont les trois nouvelles voies
intégré à l'application waze après votes
des utilisateurs a laissé bord ou locaux
la gare pour essayer rendez-vous dans
les paramètres rubrique voix et son et
mieux vaut tester l'option avant de
l'adopter
chez lohr a défendu le caractère tous
trois bières bonne réponse
incroyable c'est
en fait donne deux personnages
politiques un peu anciennes que le jeune
charles de gaulle par exemple
ne dites plus allez on y va mais plutôt
de quoi surprendre un peu jessica et
morgane entrepreneurs sont pour son
marseillaise grande utilisatrice de
l'application
elle nous tu toi au moins c'est la
copine un guidage made in marseille avec
quelques subtilités
spectaculaire ce questionnaire le show
oui moi je fais pas autre chose
[Rires]
j'y lis pas les chippendales
c'est parti comment se mettre à nu dans
une assiette ah
mais non
réalisé le premier qui dit que c'est la
journée des brocolis
plein d'espoir on ne peut pas appeler
pourtant d'ailleurs plein d'espoir que
nous vers une journée lippert ensoleillé
très généreux le temps la reine
aurait-elle trouvé le moyen de faire
passer des messages à sa manière
en 2017 le vote du bric site est à
l'ordre du jour
la reine à qui l'on prête des
convictions pro-européenne n'hésite pas
à arborer lors de son discours
d'ouverture un grand chapeau bleu à
fleur jaune
qui n'est pas sans rappeler le drapeau
européen
c'est pas chez que c'est pas classe et
pas élégant ma belle voilà le message
en courant dans le stress est dans la
rapidité voilà je glisse sur le sol je
me retape je me relèverai tout va bien
tu rigoles qui faisait peur que de mal à
marne-la-vallée faut croire que même
ikea avait besoin de décompresser un peu
vous ne dormez pas assez la semaine et
vous pensez récupérer en rallongeant
votre sommeil le week-end et bien vous
vous trompez nous disent les chercheurs
de l'université américaine de l'arizona
les grasses matinées des règles
l'horloge biologique et provoque un
stress très important pour notre corps
les chercheurs appellent ça le jet lag
social en fait c'est un peu comme si
vous faisiez un aller retour paris new
york tous les week-ends en faisant la
grasse matinée moi je vous cache pas que
c'est la plume de ma couette qui me
manque un peu ce matin donc il reste 5
minutes pour finir de préparer télématin
avec vue à vie mais on sera là en
attendant allez préparer mon petit dodo
amis tomates et ce décalage horaire dans
votre sommeil du week-end augmenterait
même de 11 % le risque de développer des
maladies cardiovasculaires carrément
dangereux quoi c'est mauvais pour la
santé c'est du stress de la fatigue en
plus pascal riché
toi
enfin la fusée de la victoire avec toi
le père et et je suis super content
parce que j attendais ce mois
[Musique]
j'avais envie
ouf
alors
on peut en rire c'est vrai quoi on
aurait pu essayer de travailler sur
quelque chose un petit peu plus chic et
épurées notamment au niveau de la
présentation alors ça vous devez enlever
c'est une salade
ça me convient
[Musique]
bon j'y vais pas
il ya un piano alors ça c'est le plus
parfait mélange ça c'est le vrai mélange
caylar là là et mon art ça c'est pour
les amis
je voulais juste vous montrer ce qui se
passe en ce moment au vi sur la
température qui ont été prises entre
1980 et 2010 regarder en avant 1970
c'était plutôt fluctuant un jour 1,8
année en affichant une année on avait
froid et depuis 1970 c'est bien ça monte
ça monte ça monte comme ça régulièrement
en ayant toujours sud est normal on est
toujours au dessus des normales de
saison ça ne fluctuent pu et ça monte de
plus en plus rapidement alors ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est totalement rassurant
votre truc